today we feature two-time guest Dr Gad
sad a marketing genius renowned for
applying evolutionary psychology to
Consumer Behavior he's a professor at
Concordia University a behavioral
scientist and a best-selling author can
you do something unique that makes you
stick out from that clutter you may know
him from his extremely successful
YouTube channel the sad truth or you may
know him from his previous appearance on
the into the impossible podcast where we
discussed his book The pardic Mind in
which he foretold of what would become
of society starting in 2020 and he was
uncan accurate he explored how
infectious ideas are killing common
sense but instead of leading us to the
proverbial cat it leads us to the abyss
of infinite lunacy today though we dive
into a happier topic the sad truth about
happiness join us for an insightful
conversation discover the eight secrets
of leading a good life even during Times
Like These of War conflict famine and
pestilence Professor sad how are you my
good friend so good to be with you again
thank you for having me we're going to
go deep into happiness we're going to go
into get into a little uh thermodynamics
actually today and I know that with your
mathematics background at that scourge
of the Ivy Leagues Cornell you will uh
be able to hang with that but uh the
first thing I wanted to ask you is why
do we need another book on happiness our
our mutual friend Dennis Prager uh who
we've both been uh involved with is
Prager University uh which which is you
know we we you and I believe that that's
a real University right G I mean I just
want to make it clear for the the people
in the car that's not a real university
did you know that yes we're aware of it
but uh but we have all sorts of fake
professors in the world like uh my
favorite uh Professor Galloway Scott
Galloway or Professor who also wrote a
happiness book or Professor Dave finina
who has a bachelor's degree I believe um
so anyway Gad why do we need another
happiness book there's so many of them
out there that's a great question and it
actually made it daunting for me to
decide whether I should delve into
writing a book on happiness if you would
have asked me three years ago on the
heels of the parasitic mind coming out
what would be some of my future book
projects I would have never told you
that oh yes the next one is it looks
like it's going to be a happiness book
and so as many things in life it was
through some serendipitous forces so it
was really two reasons why I wrote the
book and then I'll I'll answer the
question of you know why we need another
happiness book in in answering in the
way that I will in a second number one I
would get many many emails from people
saying how is it that you can tackle so
many difficult sensitive dangerous
corrosive subjects and yet you always
seem to have a twinkle in your eye
you're always smiling you don't take
yourself seriously you do all these
funny satirical skits you're playing
around what's your secret Professor how
are you so happy so that was one the
second thing is that you know whenever I
would post something that is
prescriptive usually as an evolution AR
psychologist as a consumer psychologist
I operate in descriptive world I just
describe why humans do the things that
they do prescriptive world is typically
reserved for clinical psychologists or
self-help gurus and but whenever I would
post something that was prescriptive on
my social media which to me seemed like
a like a banale call to action that
would be some of the stuff that would be
most impactful to people oh my God you
don't know how much you've changed my
life by telling me the four steps to
losing weight and how you lost weight
that I've lost 80 pounds now because of
you professor and so I thought okay well
people want to know what's my secret to
happiness they want to they seem to
really trust trust me as a source of
dispensing information well why don't I
take a crack at writing a book but to
your point if there is one topic that
philosophers have most written about
it's the good life it's well-being it's
happiness so what can I add That's
Unique well here is how I tackled it my
stories my personal experiences are
unique to me so there is that coupled
with the ancient wisdoms backed up by
the Contemporary science put that
together and I think if I've done a good
job uh you have a unique book yeah it
covers so many different topics and uh
there's there is a prescriptive element
to it but I would say it's also
exploratory in sort of a hero's journey
fashion of how you have with tangible
you know outcomes and and supporting
anecdotes which I you know they always
say the plural of data is not anecdotes
or the other way around I guess but um
but in reality uh I think for me looking
at all these books it seems kind of uh
hopeless on one hand anybody can write a
book about happiness right I mean my my
you know toddler might be happy and uh
you could everything I needed to learn I
learned in kindergarten which I say I
updated that I wrote a book called
everything I needed to know I learned in
advanced relativistic astrophysics in
Graduate School uh but uh but you know I
think for professors writing it it
always strikes me as as really kind of
ridiculous because we I always joke we
have the you know the hardest three-
hour a week job in the world right I
mean we we teach for three hours we
maybe U you know supervise some graduate
students a couple more hours it's it's
super fun correct me if I'm wrong G I
hope you know I don't know is your every
universities public there yes we don't
have the public uh private distinction I
I I might push back a bit on we only
work three hours a week I actually work
very very long hours every day but to
your more General point I don't view it
at work as work because I'm so fulfilled
in my job so I and I discussed that in
one of the chapters where I talk about
how to choose the right profession so
it's not that I don't work very hard but
I never feel as though I'm working
because I engage in play I've got
another chapter on Life as a playground
so you and I get paid to engage in the
highest form of Play It's called science
it's called Academia it's called
navigating through the world of ideas
and I get paid for that my God I'm a
lucky guy it's like getting paid to be
an ice cream taster although you don't
do that although today it look like you
had a lot of syrup on those Flapjacks
but that was B but it was Zionist who
forced me to do that was that turkey
bacon the Zionist made you eat bacon or
is that turkey bacon it was kosher bacon
okay good so I always bring a proof you
you'll be interested to know this uh
what is the proof that being a professor
is the best job on Earth you know what
the proof is Gad is it a rhetorical
question or you really asking me I'm
just uh well I if you have proof I'd be
interested I have I have 100% loctip
proof for me on a personal level I don't
think there's you know objective metrics
that prove that but for me it's the
perfect profession because it allows me
to do the two things that I talk about
in the book in terms of how to seek
occupational happiness number one it
allows me to immerse myself within my
creative impulse right I talk about how
you know a stand-up comic a podcaster an
author a professor an architect a chef
they are operating in completely
different domains but they do share one
thing in common they are creating
something from nothing which didn't
exist until they came along and put
together those jokes or that plate of
delicious food or that bridge or that
book and so the process of engaging in
in in you know instantiating a creative
impulse by definition is one that grants
you immediate purpose and meaning
because it's it's meaningful to create
something new so that's one number
number two the temporal Freedom that I
get with my job yes I've got a schedule
yes we had to push our meeting by a few
minutes because I had a whole bunch of
other meetings but I I feel like I'm a
in French you say FL you know I vagabon
around right so now I go off to a cafe I
start thinking about the book prectice
for my next book then I might have a
meeting with a graduate students so how
is the data looking is it supporting our
hypothesis then I go off and read some
really cool book then I I vagabon some
more so even though I'm I'm I'm never
leaving my work in that my work is
really my brain my mind uh I'm not bound
by any you know if I were a pilot once
that door closes the six hours I'm
locked not only physically I'm locked
temporally for those next six hours
because I don't have that I feel that
Academia is the perfect job for me
what's your explanation well actually
it's uh fortuitous that you brought up
Pilots because the the proof text for
this is a pilot by the name of Neil
Armstrong and he was the first human
being to walk on the moon as you know
and he was accompanied by Buzz Aldren
who was uh who was also a pilot uh and
these two men had the you know Peak
experience and I want to get into you
know kind of the hedonic treadmill and
anticipatory happiness and what I call
the relativity of Happiness later on but
speaking of Neil Armstrong the only job
that was fit for him after he walked on
the surface of the Moon the most famous
man on Earth was become a professor of
engineering at the University of
Cincinnati so if that doesn't go to show
he could have done anything literally
anything and he chose to become a
professor um and you know well I mean
the reason I sort of you know push back
on on professors and and so forth is a
lot of my colleagues are miserable I
mean I would say you are kind of an
exception these are people again who are
working you know the good ones not that
you know the assistant professors you
know pre-tenure uh they're working their
butts off they're doing great work
they're you know they're playing the
academic game The Hunger Games they're
making Publications they're being on
committees they're doing supervision of
students they're teaching big classes
they're getting good they're doing all
this stuff once you get 10 a lot of you
know people around the country that do
my job and by the way there's more
people in the NBA a that are
experimental cosmologist you know it's
not a big field but once you get Beyond
a certain point people get comfortable
and they don't really do much or they
complain about how much they have to do
so when I talk to a theoretical
physicist I say well you haven't written
a paper in in 20 years that has more
than 10 citations you know some my
graduate students have a higher H index
than you um why do you not like U you
know teach two classes so that I may
only teach you know half as I would I
would I would rebel I would I would
complain to the dean so what is it about
people is it is that that we become so
accustomed to a level of you know
hedonic adaptation maybe that we then uh
the bar for happiness becomes that much
higher and that might explain why so
many of our colleagues are miserable
twits what a great question I I think
frankly it's because a lot of people who
go into Academia I think when you
started your question you said you know
the assistant professors play the game I
think once you're playing the game in
the pejorative sense not in the sense of
when I say life as a playground you're
playing a
game yeah exactly for extrinsic reasons
then ultimately once you are protected
by the cushy life of tenure then you no
longer do it because all along you did
it for extrinsic reasons now in my case
and again that we could link that to
another chapter in the book where I talk
about variety seeking specifically
intellectual variety seeking if if my
graduate students were to tell me should
I emulate your career path I'm going to
answer them in one of two ways and it's
going to speak to your general question
about the Deadwood after tenure so in in
Academia as you well know Brian uh the
best way to to to do well is to be a
stay in your lane academic know a lot
about a very small thing and then keep
pumping out the papers with plus Epsilon
plus Delta because you already have the
economies of scale of the literature
review of the methodology so I'll just
add a plus Epsilon here comes another
paper another paper that nobody will
ever read or give a about but at
least I am playing the game now being
the purest that I am I from day one I
rebelled against this I said I realize
that that's what the game is but life is
too short for me to play it so therefore
I have published in medical journals in
politics in Psychology in marketing
Inus in data Fusion for architecture for
maritime surveillance that I have not
published in that no you have you have
absolutely I can prove it what are you
talking about I'm looking at Google
Scholar at your homepage right now your
number one sided paper has 71 citations
data Fusion architecture for maritime oh
I'm sorry that's Ahmed sad Gad that's
Ahmed sad Gad I I I knew there was a
joke coming because me exactly that's
another guy he's also pretty broad he's
published on sexual selection in
Ferraris in Berk now just good yeah no
uh people might not get those references
so so you know I've published an
evolutionary theory evolutionary ology
consumer psychology advertising because
you know if Brian tomorrow you come
along and say hey let's publish a paper
where I think I could contribute as an
author and it's going to be published in
the annals of physics I go yes sign me
up what a cool Journey let's do it right
even though from the perspective of the
metrics that are rewarded within my
field people would say why would you
publish a paper with this guy it's going
to get you nowhere I don't care right
now how is that related related to your
original question well the academics
that decide the day after I I become
tenur I stop by definition are
exhibiting the fact that they did
everything that they did for extrinsic
reasons not intrinsic reasons right
whereas to a fault everything that I do
comes from a place of Purity and I say
to a fault because it has literally
harmed my career in many specific ways
so I'll give you an example there was a
University from Southern California
where I very much desired to to move to
that was very keen on hiring me and when
I went to give a talk there it was a
talk demonstrating the applicability of
evolutionary theory to a very broad
range of fields in in my own research so
here's how I apply it with with hormones
here's how I apply it with the menstrual
cycle here's how I apply it with PE
cocking with with with the Porsches here
in politics in medicine and so I thought
that's a wonderful thing because you
universities usually say from this side
of their mouth we support
interdisciplinarity but from this side
of their mouth they told me well you
know we view your CV as though it's
quite unfocused because you don't seem
to have a singular line of research and
so but
again who ends up winning is it your
colleague who no one knows or and I say
this not to be egotistical or is it the
Professor who when I walk down 100
meters I'm stopped by 11 people in those
100 meters so again it depends how you
wish to live your life I want to live my
life so that I can do something
meaningful and the fact that many people
resonate with my message suggests that
maybe I'm doing something a bit more
important than your bu colleague let me
um take a break for a second because I
forgot on all the excitement and all my
technical difficulties I forgot to do my
favorite game which we've started since
you were on last time for parasitic mind
we started a new segment on the into the
impossible podcast and it's called
judging books by their covers because
what the hell else does somebody have to
go on besides the title the picture the
cover uh the subtitle and so I want you
to walk us through this uh design
process and then uh just to demonstrate
that how much I love this book not only
did I read it and uh make it through to
the acknowledgement section but the true
sign of love and you'll you'll I think
validate this is when a reader can point
out a typo in the book uh oh oh you're
triggering my maladaptive perfectionism
that's right so now we have it in real
time so first take us through the book
take us through the cover the design
these penetrating uh blue eyes my wife
was just staring at it uh she had to
wrestle it out of her hands uh this
handsome Hebrew hunk please tell me sir
the title subtitle and why you chose a
picture of yourself for the cover I
think for the first what a great
question because well first of all it's
the first time I've ever had someone ask
asked me that so kudos for your creative
generation of questions number one
number two it it actually speaks to
something that's relevant in marketing
right packaging right so can you know
there is a infinite clutter of books can
you do something unique that makes you
stick out from that clutter I have a
whole lecture in my consumer psychology
course where I talk about the perceptual
system and you know what are some tricks
that we can do to break ourselves from
the Clutter okay so here's how that
process went they thought and I I'm I'll
say it here publicly and openly I I I'm
not 100% sure that it was the best
decision some people thought it looked
too much like a kind of Oprah Garden
variety uh magazine uh others thought oh
no it's I am extremely good-look and
sexy so why not you know utilize lean in
uh and so that was the AR so people knew
who I was so putting me on the cover
would make sense so that was their logic
the sad truth about happiness came from
the fact that obviously the sad truth is
a well-known brand sad of course is a
play on sad sad truth about happiness
and also my editor thought that this
because the brand sad truth is so well
known it might become part of an ongoing
series yes where I do you know the sad
truth about evolutionary psychology the
sad truth about the Middle East the sad
so that was the general idea but I don't
know did we do a good job did you do you
like it or would you have changed some
things what are your thoughts I like it
a lot I mean it's it kind of reminds me
you know of of you know going into uh my
parents were getting divorced and I'd go
in and meet with their therapist you
know at the same time um or lawyer I
don't know which is worse but uh no it's
it's very good and Regner always does a
good job with their with their
publishing um and binding and so forth
um but so now we have this un the the
unpleasantness to get to um hi I'm so
sorry to interrupt this delightful fun
happiness inducing episode with Gad sad
but do you know what would make me
really happy if you subscribe to this
YouTube channel YouTube analytics tells
me that only 133% of you watching this
are subscribed which is too
bad because you're missing out on the
greatest and latest episodes that tell
us about where we fit into the cosmos
the search for meaning and great guests
are coming up in the end the impossible
podcast ranging from Nobel Prize winners
to sure to be audience favorites like
MOA do himself an author of a book about
happiness so do me a favor subscribe
right now before you forget it's free
and you can leave anytime although I
hope you won't thanks a billion now back
to the episode yeah so I know you are um
not necessarily a Biblical scholar you
are incredibly wise in arite when it
comes to the Bible and its impact on
society uh but there is a sentence in
here if you are an orthodox Jew for
example there are 6113 mitz vote uh
religious rules which is correct and 10
commandments so I want to I say you said
and there are Ten Commandments you said
613 mits vote and there are 10 and and
10 but actually the 10 are part of the
613 ah so so it's not and the 10 are
subsumed within the 613 that's right so
we believe thank you so much for
publicly shaming me I appreciate that is
there anything else do you want to talk
about how I rais my children wrongly or
anything else yes when when you talked
about how uh you can eat uh that you
preferred the Nobel Prize to money I I I
just have a personal bone to pick with
it's not a typo God but I believe that
um and and this is where I want to get
into it you say in the book effectively
you'd rather have a Nobel Prize or
associate with Nobel Prize winners or
you're more interested in hearing what a
Nobel Prize winner has than these
billionaires that solicit you for paid
lectures right so um because people
lineing up around the block to listen to
people like you and Nobel I do believe
that there are that the Nobel Prize is
sort of a kosher Idol that people aspire
to and and obviously I've written a book
about it but U but more than that that
everybody even the most irreligious
amongst us which you know I I don't
think you practice I think you're you're
phos Semitic and and and of course
you're deeply Ste steeped in in the
Middle East and and in your uh culture
and um and and your religion even so you
don't practice though however I do
believe that almost it is almost
impossible not to have a religion and
that could be money it could be Fame it
could be being a professor playing a
role or it could be aspiring to win a
Nobel Prize so talk to me about like how
how do we sometimes assuage oursel oh um
I'm going on Tik Tok but it's not as bad
as eating a pile of donuts like do we do
or I'm I'm aspiring to win a Nobel Prize
but at least I'm not trying to get a
Ferrari are do we have ways of of of
kind of um what's the psychological term
for this dis displacing our desires and
making them seem more uh kosher or Noble
than they actually are I mean it's I can
answer that in one of several ways but
first to your original what you
referenced in the book uh the the
tension there was not between meeting
billionaires or a Nobel Prize winner the
specific story and and I know you were
kind of speaking off the cuff but just
because that the story is very powerful
it was I was going I was traveling with
a family member and I was explaining
that I was very excited that I would uh
be meeting a not just a Nobel Prize
winner it wasn't so much that he was a
Nobel Prize winner but it was that it
was herb Simon who is first of all a
polymath in the truest sense of the term
he he exactly exemplifies the way that
I've tried to live my career which is
you know he's a professor of everything
right he's a professor of administrative
sciences and a and and a Pioneer in Ai
and a behavioral decision theorist and a
psychologist and he's everything okay
and so I thought my God that's amazing
he also happened to know my uh doctoral
supervisor well at the time he just
recently retired my doctor supervisor
he's a cognitive psychologist by the
name of J Russo actually a very quick
Side Story so there uh my doctoral
supervisor at one point was on the uh
doctoral Committee of a student who
subsequently became himself a very
well-known decision theorist and the
other committee members were uh Amos
derski who would have won the Nobel
Prize with Conan had he had he lived
long enough to win it and Herb Simon so
it was herb Simon a Nobel Prize winner
amosi who we could say won the Nobel
Prize I mean posum asly and Jay Jay
Russo who was my supervisor and he tells
he told me once a very funny story you
know Jay was a very is a very
self-confident guy he goes you know God
it isn't very often that I am the
dumbest person in the room but when I
sat on that committee I was clearly the
dumbest guy now what I took away from
that story is that it doesn't matter
whatever you if you go to prison and you
think you are the toughest of the
toughest there is somebody in there
who's probably uh stronger and tougher
and more violent than you if you think
you're the top of the top there's always
someone who's going to be better than
you in Academia so that maybe speaks to
your other question I'm not going to
tackle it directly but one of the things
I talk about in the book is that uh
happiness is a positional emotion in
that the the the calculus that we use in
judging how happy we are is not simply
as a function of some set level that we
reach but it's a function of a reference
comparison to some other relevant group
so the the the beautiful example of that
is uh the relationship between sex and
happiness how how often do you have sex
and happiness well it probably won't
surprise many people that all other
things equal more sex equals happier but
the next part is the one that's kind of
surprising what really makes me happy is
not only that I have a lot of sex but I
have more sex than all of my close
friends so if Brian has no sex and I
have a lot of sex my ticket to happiness
and so that demonstrates that we really
are a social speak species that uses
these really important hierarchies to
judge where we stand and therefore that
makes me either happy or unhappy yeah
and I I wanted only to um to recommend
if there is a version that corrects the
typo that
egregious you know moat in in your eye
forever more that is dedicated the
acknowledgements to Professor Brian
keading that you call positional
happiness relativity of happiness
because we got to get some more physics
in here for me I I thought of that right
because you know our good friend Galileo
and Einstein they came up with this
notion that no person can say truly
Who's In Motion it's completely a
relative phenomenon it doesn't mean
everything is relative like the pop
psychologist will say but uh going on
this this this you know continuing on
this tangent no pun intended of kind of
the relativity or positionality uh you
speak of these u-shaped curves and even
with sex I mean there's a funny vignette
in the talmud you know this is the
second holiest book in Judaism where
they talk about the relative obligations
of various professions to satisfy their
wives okay we're going to keep it
relatively clean and and actually some
of it makes it into the so-called CBA
the wedding document which is actually a
prenuptual agreement that you know we
Jews hang on our walls many of us uh so
it's kind of funny when your kids are
old enough to read the Hebrew and say
you have to give Mommy was a virgin that
you have to give three camels to what is
or zims what the hell is a zuzim anyway
um the talid speculates that you know a
stone breaker you know basically has so
much testosterone they didn't know what
it was but you know he has to have sex
all the time and his wife wants sex with
him that's why she married him he's like
super hunky you know like uh you know uh
and then but like a talmudic scholar
who's an austere religious scholar is so
wrapped up in the mentality that he
can't be expected to have sex more than
like some minimum number of encounters
per month uh and I always thought that
was that was kind of interesting that
there's a in Judaism there's a maximum
minimum for everything including tithing
you can't give too much money you can't
you have to give a minimum amount but
all these things what isn't it true that
at some point there I mean the u-shape
really can is present in many different
um uh phenomena from in the happiness
Spectrum can you talk about you know yes
beyond that yeah yeah that thank you for
that question so you know going back to
my mathematics uh background one of the
things that interested me is just
functional forms here is a a a shape
what would be the polom that would
perfectly match that and then that's how
I at one point in the introduction of
that chapter I talk about fractal Theory
and mendal Brad right where you're able
to map all of these irregular shapes
using a you know a very easily
understood recurring algorithm right and
so as I was thinking about all this I
said if I were to try to think of a
functional form that is the most
universal in nature that that best can
serve as a prescriptive tool for how to
live the good life what would it be and
aha it was you shape so then I did a
first a bit of a deep dive into the
different Traditions that have
recognized that throughout the Millennia
so of course most famously is Aristotle
with his golden mean uh in the uh nikom
makian ethics where you know if you're a
soldier if you're too cowardly that's
not good if you're so reckless in your
bravery that you become an unnecessary
martyr that's not good and there is some
golden mean in the middle but to our
ancestor my manes also recognized the
inverted you Al I mean although he
didn't call it the inverted you but the
the middle the Buddhist called it the
middle way confucious also talked about
that so many different independent
cultural Traditions have arrived at the
same point that life is about Temperance
now what I did in that chapter Brian is
I said okay my mind operates very
synthetically in that so I that's why I
love the book by EO Wilson consilience
right consilience is unity of knowledge
Building Bridges across the social
sciences the humanities and the Natural
Science so I'm always trying to draw
connections between things that here to
for had not been connected so I thought
okay my chapter is going to be to
demonstrate the universality and the
ubiquity of the inverted you across a
bewildering number of phenomena at many
different units of analysis so I could
do it at the neur Al level at the
individual level at the economic level
at the societal level so I could show
that different phenomena all obey this
too little not good too much not good we
call scale and variance right exactly
perfect exactly and so if you want I
could give you a few examples from
different fields so here is one that
speaks to your earlier identifying a an
error in the in the book so
perfectionism follows in as a as a
personality trait follows the inverted
you because if you're not in the least
bit perfectionist your let's say as an
author your work will suffer there's no
attention to details all of your
references are going who cares if I get
the issue wrong who yeah come on it's
okay if you are at the other end of the
curve where I am in the maladaptive end
past the inflection point well you are
reading the galley proofs of your book
instead of it taking three days you take
two weeks because God forbid you find a
typo and yet Brian keting finds an error
with the 16 613 Ms vote so that speaks
to me being mortified that I might miss
a comma of reference now why is that sub
suboptimal because even when despite all
of my maladaptive perfectionism there
was an error that was found and you
found it and okay so big big deal
ultimately the two extra weeks that I
took that to try to find that error
maybe it would have been better spent
working on my next book perspectus right
and so that would be an example of how I
am poorly calibrated on perfectionism
and I need to go back towards the left
inflection point romantic jealousy in a
relationship if you're not in the least
bit if you never exhibit romantic
jealousy your partner will often try to
trigger romantic jealousy because a
complete lack of jealousy often times
signals that I actually don't care
enough about you because it seems to be
so uh anomalous that I would never
trigger any jealousy in me then they
will try to gauge whether I'm gonna
speak to another guy in a very
flirtatious manner okay on the other
hand if I'm too far along in my jealousy
where I'm checking up on you 17 times
that could be the precursor of me being
a really bad and abusive and domineering
partner somewhere in the middle lies the
optimal level of romantic jealousy uh
how much stress you're exposed to this
is from Robert supulski the
neuroanatomist from Stanford not any
stress is not good too much stress
stultifies you somewhere in the middle
is the optimal so for a number of
bewildering examples inverted you is the
way to go yeah career ambition uh
working out physicality all these
examples that you give in the book um
and what's nice about that you're not
you you you do distill it to actionable
information although it's not a
self-help guide necessarily as such but
um but to think about you know these
these different you know topics just the
ones that you brought up uh I found that
yes there I mean there's a vol quote
right that Perfection is the enemy of
the good enough or you know perfect is
the enemy and other things you know
Perfection is p you know procrastination
masquerading is productivity so all
these quotes but but you know towards
like fi yes you'll never find all I mean
it's impossible there are people that
are paid that just sit in a room with
like a magnifying glass looking at and
I'm sure regnery did that too um and and
then there's domain specific stuff
obviously but um but sometimes it's it's
like open sourcing it like crowd
sourcing it you tell I tell my kids if
they find an error in my videos or my my
books or whatever you know I'll I'll
I'll smack them no no I'll buy them you
know some some nice treat or or you know
let them watch Tik Tok or something like
that um and similarly for like gel I've
heard about ways to automate you know in
our society now we can automate things
and I just heard about like a service
that allows you to to send flowers to
your spouse to your wife right so you do
it it's a monthly subscription so she'll
get flowers every month and then I I was
thinking like an add-on could be like
every so often they throw in like it's
from a stranger so like she's like
what's what the hell's going on here
like I thought you know I've got a
secret admire you know maybe she you
know that's interesting because as as
you may know from whatever knowledge you
have from psychology watch your channel
yeah oh thank you schedules of
reinforcements in in operand or scaran
conditioning right uh the idea is
there's a schedule of either Rewards or
punishment that can shape the behavior
of humans but certainly of a pigeon
right aarian with okay well there you
when you're talking about schedules of
reinforcement you typically talk about
either a variable schedule of
reinforcement or a a you you know a a I
can't remember what the term for non no
well that would be random is the
variable the other one is maybe
continuous I can't remember what the the
formal term is so for example if I said
every first Tuesday of the month I send
my wife the flowers that is different
than if I say on average every Tuesday
but it could come on Friday to come and
so depending on what my goal is in terms
of my learning schedule in some
instances a variable schedule is
preferred to a non-variable one so in
your case it may be
worthwhile think of sex for example
what's more interesting
spontaneous uh sexual encounters or
every Saturday after we tuck the kids to
bed is our sexy time probably the former
so you might want to revisit your
schedule of reinforcements all right yes
I'll I'll introduce random rewards and
and Punishment you got you can't have
the reward without the punishment all
right Gad I have to um I have to move to
a to a somber a more somber note um the
the same Torah that has 623 I mean 613
mitzvot one of the there's several mitz
vote and um one of them is that you
should be happy on Shabbat and the other
one is that you shall rejoice and be
happy you shall have Simka on your
holidays and as you know this past year
not only on Shabbat but on Simka Tor the
and the culmination of peak experience
for the Jewish people which happened to
coincide with the Shabbat uh there was
the worst massacre of Jews since the
Holocaust and I I don't know what day of
the Holocaust you know and there were
probably days that didn't even make it
to that level so the catastrophe that
befell our people um and and people of
the world that weren't Jewish obviously
there's hundreds of there's Americans
that are still being held hostage there
um and many Jew non-jews you know the
obvious question that I'm going to ask
you how can we be happy you you had a
tweet I was trying to find it I you
pinned it for a while it's gone I I
can't really find it but maybe you'll
send it to me again but it expressed a
Darkness a pessimism that I'm not used
to associating with you Gad and it made
me worried for you but then you know
it's kind of like when your pilot starts
freaking out on the plane you know
there's no hope it's pretty it's pretty
terrifying and so I want to ask you you
know I I'm still crying you know I will
still find myself moved to tear not not
by the just the sheer horror I mean I've
I've gotten kind of in nerd to that but
the moments of just like just insane
beautiful Humanity or just crushing you
know the the the you know the Survivor
guilt that I'm hearing from survivors
anyway you know what I'm GNA ask you so
H how how how can you and I and and
anyone with a conscience how can we I
feel like it's going to be hard to be
happy again I know felt that way after
911 in a very similar way but this is so
much more concentrated against a
specific group of people and it's
happening pograms are happening you know
on campuses you know around the world
and I'm worried about it coming to my
own campus so tell me go H how do you
react to this yeah thank you for that
question uh boy yeah we went from
happiness to boom I know no no I
understand uh the tweet in question by
the way the the sentiments that you
expressed when you said wait a second if
if Gad is no longer smiling we're in
trouble that sentiment was sent to me by
you can't imagine how many people some
very famous people some complete
unknowns uh I mean Megan Kelly mentioned
it on her show where she said when I saw
the the the the the tone of that tweet I
said oh boy I better worry if Gad is
speaking like that because he's he's the
happy warrior the somber note of that
tweet really came from
a a Confluence of factors what number
one is the tragedy that befell on
October 7th so if nothing else happens
that's enough to make you say oh my God
here we go again okay so that's number
one number two I like to use the
following analogy when when I was losing
all my weight I instead of breaking it
up into the long journey of eventual
weight loss I had to get to it was a
daily chunking of information which was
at the end of each day if I've made the
right decisions or if I haven't only one
of three things can happen I mean
literally there are only three states of
the world as relating to the metric of
my weight my weight could either go up
that day as compared to the previous day
it could stay exactly the same or it
could go down there is no other possible
state of the world right okay well that
seems like a banale point but it's
actually quite profound because let's
apply it now to immediately after the
October 7 tragedy one of three things
can happen happen when it comes to
either the love or disdain for Jews
there could be global increase of love
for the Jews there could be no change in
the love for the Jews or there could be
a massive decrease or increased hatred
of the Jews well we can all agree that
at the global level what we've seen is
an unleashing of global Jew hatred that
even for someone with my background left
me breathless so that's point two of
that somber
uh tweet that you mentioned which by the
way went really I'm not saying it to
brag but it really was so uh powerful
that I think it was read by I don't know
how many 20 15 million people or
something okay point three of that the
somber tone of that email the old cliche
is the first step to recognize to to
solving a problem is to recognize that
you have a problem or whatever the
cliche is right yeah I I can't I can't
solve my alcoholism if I don't admit
that I'm an alcoholic that's step one
right and then I have if I accept that
then I can take steps to hopefully
alleviate the problem so many of the
realities that have led us to exactly
the position that we're at today have a
set of intervention strategies that can
help us improve the situation so we can
do ab c d now what if I told you that we
are doubling down on every single one of
the parasitic ideas and parasitic
policies that have led us to where we
are then it's a lost cause right and so
the analogy to that is you go see your
physician Brian God forbid a million
times he says you've got stage
four aggressive cancer so then your
answer is first of all there is no such
thing as cancer second of all if there
is such a thing as cancer it's the Jew's
fault third of all if there is a
solution for cancer it's the Jews who
are holding it and not giving it to us
because that's how they make money and
increase the prices of chemotherapy
fourth of all I'm going to smoke four
packs a day I'm going to inhale deep
inhalations from an asbestos bag and
then I'm going to suntan in an
artificial sunbed for five hours that is
my prescriptive
interventions to my physician saying
you've got aggressive stage for cancer
well I can't then feel very optimistic
so this positionally I'm optimistic to a
fault I wake up I'm excited life is I
don't like to go to sleep because I'm so
excited how can we fasten fasten the
thing so we can get to tomorrow I'm so
excited for the next day but when I see
what's happening and I see the absolute
inability of the West to autocorrect on
any Dimension if anything we double down
on everything that's why I wrote the
tweet in question and in terms of
dealing with the you know kind of you
know horrific aath maath you know I'm
putting my my daughter to bed you know
and there's and there's millions of you
know of of of daughters around the world
of course but this one's mine and and
I'm looking and thinking you know I bet
these people felt the same way it was
just an ordinary night the night before
and you quote a lot from senica and a
lot from epicus and the and the great
stoics of of of the past but you know
there's a line I think from Marcus
aelius where he's like you know when you
put your child to bed you know tell
yourself this is the last I won't see
them in the morning whether they'll die
you'll die whatever I've always found
that you know it's it if you really did
that there's a famous Simpsons episode
you know back before they went
completely woke uh you know where Homer
is talking to to somebody and he's like
you just got to live every day like it's
your last and then they cut the Homer in
the next second like I'm gonna die
tomorrow I'm gonna die tomorrow he's
like falling his eyes out but can you
really you know can you really enact
instantiate the prescriptive you know
kind of fives of these of these great uh
you know uh stoic ver you know basically
how can you deal with this I've heard
things like a parent who hasn't lost a
child and God forbid a thousand times
right they can't relate you know to
someone who had there's nothing they can
say like people say oh I'm a dog Dad I'm
a oh yeah your dog died you're gonna get
another dog okay fine your kid died I
mean come on so I I find some of these
kind of even from the stoics
platitudinous so how do you react what I
might say might either move you
immensely or you might think it's cliche
I think I hope that it's a former and I
actually gave this answer recently to I
was interviewed by India today and the
guy then wrote to me the deput editor
and said of everything that you said in
the show this is what moved me the most
and I'm going to say it hopefully it
will move you in the same way maybe not
I say the biggest revenge against all of
the enemies of human dignity is to live
a dignified life and so therefore you
know when we went through very very very
very deep dark difficulties in in
Lebanon my parents were kidnapped by fat
every single minute of every day growing
up in the Lebanese Civil War was
literally had the potential of being the
last day if someone knocked at your door
there was a very very good chance that
this was going to be the end of you we
we would decide whether to duck under
the the the the beds as a function of
the whistle signature of the bomb so you
look learn how to recognize how close
the bomb shellings are by virtue of the
right my parents would tell me if you go
outside don't don't cross this
particular line uh outside on the street
because that opens you up to the snipers
in that building and they'll blow your
brain so death awaited me every second
of every day and now that could have
shattered me right I I I for the next 25
years I had recurring nightmares which I
talk about in the parasitic mind and so
that could have sent me into a
psychiatric Institute it could have
turned me into a a drug addicted guy it
could have you know I could have felt a
fatalistic Doom about my life it
actually did the opposite to me it was
the ultimate antifragility stressor and
I was going to metaphorically speaking
shove it up the ass of every single
person who had harmed me directly or
indirectly I was going to live a happy
dignified successful life and so for me
even in these dark times this morning I
went for a walk with my wife and I was
to your point about it's surprising when
I'm dark I was really pissed off because
I was I I was telling her how much
longer am I going to interact with
people on social media where the Jew
hatred is coming at me from every
direction the the Uber left are
attacking me the islamists are attacking
me the Uber right neo-nazis are
attacking me and it's always this
diabolical Jewish tropes right it's you
know why did Muhammad rapes Muhammad the
a guy not the the prophet or Ahmed in in
Britain you know all those those guys
from Pakistan and so on who are raping
all those young British girls so I would
say well who who is causing those rapes
of course I want them to say well it was
those immigrants a million of these Jew
haters said yeah who let those people in
so when Muhammad or Ahmed was raping
your British daughter
he's not to blame it's the Jew it's
George Soros and the other kadre of Jews
who had the open immigration policy
right I mean so imagine how diabolical
that is Ahmed rapes your daughter you
blame mordi okay so uh yes it angers me
yes it can test my ability to be happy
but then at the end of the night I say
tomorrow is a new day I'm going to live
a dignified life I'm going to live a
meaningful life my life is going to
matter I'm going to hopefully affect
positive change and that will be my best
revenge I don't know if that offers you
it does uh but to push back with my
characteristic love and respect and
rugged good looks um I I I want to point
out there's another inverted U curve
which by the way has a symbol that you
know very well in mathematics the
intersection but that would be for your
revision second and third edition um you
know social media there's clearly you
know a ski slope downward you know
Cesspool and I've noticed it and I was I
was in Israel um on on September 7th and
I was there for two weeks uh and I was
in I I had not you know because it was
the holiday season uh before um Russia
sh and during Russia and so I had nobody
to drive me you know in the Ubers there
that are called gets you know they were
basically all uh Arabs and Muslims all
every single one I met BNS and I had
some long drives with them and we we
converted and I had meals with them it
was and I felt there was a turn I felt
like maybe for the first time there's a
possibility for Hope and maybe we can um
you know put the troubles behind us uh
and I realized it was you know it was
wishful thinking and projection and and
and the recency bias of you know just
being maybe the Palestinian Authority uh
not I wasn't in Gaza or adjacent to Gaza
but uh but the thought you know of that
now is is inconceivable and when I go on
Twitter and and part of my navit was
because I felt like well America it's
never been better to be a Jew you know
we have uh temples we have you know
religious leaders the the second
gentleman is a Jew uh the the former
first daughter was a Jew you know it's
incredible right in our whole in our
nation's capital highest office right
but now that's been totally squashed and
when I go on social media I don't have
you know I have a tenth or logarithm of
the number of media followers that you
have but you know why it it seems it
seems almost point you I posted I'm
going to talk to gadad I got Professor
Dave or you ask him about genocide you
know this is this is not a deep thinker
right uh so I want to just ask you you
know this when when would it is there a
is there a um rubric or metric that you
will use to say I'm I'm past the the
inflection point where the the
derivative is zero at the top of the
inverted you you know I actually ask
myself that question I mean this morning
when I was pissed off walking with my
wife I said you know what it's it's it's
making me into a more bitter person and
I don't I don't want to be that but on
the other hand I then feel guilty
because you know then you get a million
people who write to you saying oh my God
you know you're you're getting me
through these difficult time my God
thank you for your courage for speaking
I've even had family members whom I've
not spoken to in years write to me and
say I just wanted to thank you for what
you're doing for the you know Jewish
people and so on so it's hard because on
the one hand there is a
self-preservation mechanism that kicks
that says you know this is really vile
stuff I mean how how much can you handle
this stuff but on the other hand you
know remember in the parasitic mind I
said you know activate your inner Honey
Badger Don't diffuse responsibility now
I don't need to feel guilty about
whether I've done enough or not I've
done more than most people will do but
uh it's hard for me to walk away because
you know even when you sent me that what
that guy what's his name Professor Dave
yeah when when when you sent me that
tweet I was like oh should I just go and
hammer away at this guy and then I
walked away and I walked away precisely
because I recognize you simply can't
engage each one of those folks because
they're coming at you out of the
Woodworks but by the way going back to
your earlier question about the the dark
tweet that you mentioned look the other
reason why I think uh Darkness will
regrettably befall us for many many more
years is because the the adage
demography is Destiny is a powerful
adage because it speaks to a fundamental
truth which is again let's take that
triarte
mechanism right your weight can go up
stay the same or go down if you let in
people from cultures where according to
a wide range of global surveys often
times nonpartisan woke Global surveys
and those societies when when surveyed
exhibit 95 to
99% Jew hatred so again for your viewers
and listeners who may not follow what I
mean by that we sample a, people from
one of those countries
950 to
990 of the 1,000 sampled have terrible
views of the Jews okay so now we let in
100,000 of those people let's apply the
three states system is that going to
increase Jew hatred is it going to keep
Jew hatred the same or is it going to
decrease Jew hatred so when Professor
sad was standing on top of the mountain
seeing the demographic realities that
were unfolding and screaming from the
top of the mountain several decades ago
you're going to pay for this everybody
said oh come on but Ahmed my friend he's
a very sweet guy and he's gay and he
eats pork so clearly he represents true
Islam again it's not an attack on every
Muslim person I don't need to be
lectured about Muslims I have more
Muslim friends that most people will
ever meet in their life but does the
fact that you let in people that as part
of the DNA of their societies is a
definitional existential hatred of the
Jew will that lead to Greater Love for
the Jew no so now people wake up and say
what Cornell has a Jew problem what
Colombia what do you expect like what
else could it have been Now by now to
the point of that tweet
now are we saying okay guys let's only
let in folks that we know we could
absolutely be sure share our
foundational deontological values no
Canada is saying we're increasing
immigration to 500,000 a year so where
wherever we are today with Jew hatred
today as I speak to you next year this
time I can guarantee you it will be
worse I don't need to be a fancy
psychologist ologist or a fancy
theoretical physicist to get that point
but yet we're all going la la la
Professor sad is spewing
alarmism well I often think it's uh and
I had a lunch with a Muslim friend
yesterday secular Muslim friend and he
and I were talking about this as if it's
a um you know the the phrase the benign
bigotry of low expectations so when you
see Hamas the leader of Hamas saying you
know this was just the first Al oxa
flood there's going to be a third a
fourth and Israel's going do you mean
Gaza no no no I mean Israel I mean the
Jews the Y and then the Western media
that the only way to kind of reconcile
and grapple with that I think is to say
oh he's he's not representative and he
doesn't really mean what he says um and
it's not gonna it's not going to go
beyond the Jews problem and it's going
to be confined to to the Zionist and if
you understood Arabic and it was
probably translated he meant kill with
kindness that's why I am I am the bet no
as we say in French to all of these
because you can't pull that on right you
can do it on Brian keing you know the
Jew from San Diego you can't do it to
Arab boy right so therefore I can quote
all the stuff in Arabic I can say it
better than you can say it you know
right so so it makes it a lot a much
more of a of a problematic case right
but by the way in chapter six of the
parasitic mind I go through all that
when I I have a whole chapter on ostrich
parasitic syndrome okay well turns out
that the head of Isis with a PhD in
Islamic Studies did not understand Islam
it turns out that yusf Al karwi the top
Sunni cleric at alazhar University so
the top Islamic Theologian when he spews
all his stuff it turns out that he
doesn't understand Islam it turns out
that Saudi Arabia is not Islamic Iran is
not Islamic or Osama Bin Laden is not
Islamic you know who's Islamic Ahmed
who's gay drinks vodka and eats pork and
who's my friend and he's also an Uber
driver in San Francisco he's true Islam
so that's why that tweet is so dire
because your is impenetrable to reason
well I know we're coming up at the end
of the time you had today I just want
you have a few more minutes k sure let's
do it okay so uh I'm only Bound By the
way just for you to know I could talk to
you for hours because there's a pickup
of of the children that's that's the
only reason because it's almost 3 o00
here otherwise I would be happy the most
important thing and actually it Segways
nicely into my final set of topics um
which have to do with children and you
know that there's a there's a huge
Global movement called depopulation and
that that uh or anti-natalism is the
official academic sounding term and you
know in the limit mathematically you
know in Kramer's rule applied to a
limiting sequence you know that means
that basically maybe these people should
commit suicide and I some of them might
be in favor of of of that some of these
ideas are so odious and onerous
especially talking to people like the
Jews or like the Armenians or people
that have experienced Collective
genocide and saying well you're just
you're just fungible and your carbon
emissions are responsible for the same
amount as a nonew or non-armenian who
suffered genocide so putting that aside
um I found becoming a parent to be uh
both the the kind of you know setting
the in the dial to Infinity on on pain
potential pain but also on uh potential
happiness and obviously the happiness
you know is is makes you forget the pain
but it made me think about what I call
the entropy of Happiness if I ever write
a book it's going to be the physics of
happiness but U but the entropy of
Happiness the the idea I have is as
follows um think of all these things and
you don't have to mention by name but
think of something that would devastate
you and every parent without reflexively
can just think of something right I'm
not even going to say it because you'll
you'll tell me that you know I should
have said something else in Arabic when
I say such things but but let me just
say every parent has an instant answer
to that every single guy sorry you're
referencing this book by the way yes H
yeah well yes I am referencing yeah I
had a tweet where I said I read this
book and I read this book and they're
written by two brilliant professors uh
and you forgot to add you know one of
them you want me to tell you by the way
what it is in Arabic yeah
you
say meaning may God never compare
because you're comparing me to someone
who had their demise and that's viewed
as a big social PHA so if you do that
you you should put that qualifier that's
all right I will I will do that I will
put and all the other uh things that my
Jewish Bubbies taught me but let me just
say this so I came to this theory that
there are all these things that could
devastate you and there's way more
things yeah I think that's true even for
you there are way there's probably if I
dropped a billion dollars on you so you
didn't have to go and give a speech in
Ottawa you know and take the uh take
whatever road that is past Justin judo's
Mansion if I told you that uh you'd say
Okay billion dollars you know I'd be
happier I mean certainly you'd be
happier you could give more Sedaka
charity you could do many many things
with that start sad University with an
endowment for your first physics
Professor but um but if I told you you
know maybe it make you twice as happy
eight times as happy but um but the bad
things that I don't want to mention
would make you infinitely sad and so I I
leaned into that and I said well
shouldn't you do more of that which if
taken away from you would lead to
Devastation I actually brought this up
on your friend Lex Friedman's podcast
and Love Is Love love is love Brian is
love it is love and I wanted to just run
that by you in other words you should by
entropy it's way harder there's way more
ways we could destroy a computer than we
can make a computer there's only one way
that works right you move one circuit
board around forget it right um there's
way more ways to make your life
infinitely unhappy than make it happy so
why not try to find double your
happiness or something objective so why
not lean into that which makes you
devastated if that thing is taken away
what do you think about King's Theory
yeah wow that's a good one uh so a
couple of things I want to say there uh
number one to your point about you know
uh fertility and the the the guys who
you should not have yeah exactly thank
you that's the term I was looking for so
I I was invited was I was very honored
to be invited by the president of
Hungary to speak at a uh Budapest
demography Summit where they were
exactly addressing your general the gist
of your general question which is most
countries in the west are not producing
uh the average number of children for
the replacement rate which is around 2
point I think 2.17 and they're producing
fewer than that so that's a real problem
so they invited me to give a keynote
address where so what I did in my
address is both talk about some of the
evolutionary dynamics of families uh so
kin selection for example so on and then
I talked about what are some of the
parasitic ideas that are so hostile to
something that should be so instinctive
as you know reproducing we're sexually
reproducing species so uh I talked about
all that to your other Point again often
as as you know Brian uh what resonates
with people when they read books are the
personal stories not the the highbrow
academic stuff because we are a you know
a storytelling animal and so let me tell
you a story that speaks to the pain of
parenting it's a very personal story uh
I might have mentioned it once or tce
before uh publicly but but very rarely
so yes you didn't mention the the the
worst Calamity that a parent could ever
imagine but there's another form of if I
may say death that one can mourn and
that is when your children start growing
up and so I've always said that uh I
live in Perpetual fear of my children
becoming less Innocent by virtue of
growing up their innocence protects me
so I go out into the ugly world I fight
with the neo-nazis and the parasitized
minds and then I Retreat into this
beautiful world where innocence clean
pure innocent I love you Daddy well last
spring so not not the spring that passed
so a year and a half ago so my daughter
now is almost 15 so about a year and a
half ago I re I noticed that my daughter
was no longer playing with her
dolls and so I said oh oh I think she's
hit the developmental stage where she's
outgrown those dolls and there was a
time when her and I would play these
little scenarios with the dolls and I
would actually tape those things so we
had this whole little thing happening
but she had outgrown it and I swear to
you Brian for the next two weeks I was
you know surprisingly sad something
unaccustomed unaccustomed is that right
the right word sad because it's just not
my disposition to be sad but I felt as
though I was like in a in a kind of
dysphoric State because I was mourning
her the death of her innocence of at
least that age
now being the lovely empathetic
sensitive child that she is she then
decided okay well how to herself how can
I kind of address this well Daddy why
don't we go to the basement and play
with those
dolls that paradoxically made me sadder
Ryan can can you see where I'm going
with this because as she was playing
with me from her perspective is showing
me look I'm still your little girl I
still want to play with this I saw that
it was strained I saw that she was doing
and I literally had almost I was holding
back tears because that was the end of
that period so you're absolutely right
uh parenting sets you up for a a bol
load of pain but I wouldn't trade it for
the world because when I see them
flourishing into these young beautiful
creatures it puts everything else in
perspective yeah it's a it's a new it's
a rebirth I mean I had this you know
I've mostly Mis about Sam Harris the
what do you call him the Mantra from
Santa Monica the the Malibu meditator
the Malibu meditator I I hope to meet
him I'd like to he's never talked to a
real you know scientist of my you know
kind of profession experimental
physicist rather um and I I'd love to
you know run some stuff but he has said
certain things like you cannot be happy
you can only become happy in other words
happiness is this in unstable
equilibrium point in physical terms
physics terms and so you can you can
keep work just like I say say or Jordan
Peterson said you know you can't believe
in God like what does that even mean
like God's like waiting for you it's
like but you can give yourself short
that you can be on a path towards
developing amuna Faith whatever you want
to call it and I also feel like you know
for me it's the you know life is uh is a
lot like science like you can't science
is an infinite game but it's comprised
of a set of finite games like the Nobel
Prize tenure getting to grad school
getting an undergrad all these finite
games where they're winners and losers
uh but the whole thing is is you can't
win science but and life is like that
too and I wonder how do you balance is
my last question how do you balance you
know the kind of quest for the long-term
happiness versus like this you know this
uh this cookie is going to give me the
shortterm pleasure and that's kind of
the the ultimate kind of Sila and
caribas that I find myself I'm always
trying to I did drop thanks to a lot of
inspiration from you I did drop five
five pounds oh very good unfortunately
it's from my chin to my stomach so not
as hope not as hope but Gad tell me
please how do you balance this like the
short-term like when I'm listening to
this news I want to drink a you know a
big uh Starbucks pumpkin spice latte I
know it's pleasure long-term maybe not
happy how do you balance those those
different uh competing forces well yeah
that's that's that's that's a big
question so here we can refer to
different systems so the dopamine system
as as you know Brian and many of your
listeners and viewers would know is what
triggers or maps onto my pleasure Center
you know I I I just I'm hungry my blood
sugar is low that juicy burger yes it's
680 calories I don't give a I'm I'm
having it okay so that's that's catering
to that immediate dopamine hit when I'm
talking about in the book is of course
if we're going to continue with that
framework is the serotonin system it's
sitting on the proverbial porch with
your spouse when you're 85 and look in
the rear viw mirror of your life and say
God damn we've we've lived a good life
I've had a job that's brought me great
purpose and meaning we've raised great
kids we've had a tight Union I don't
have many things that I regret I haven't
I don't regret many things for the roads
that I did not take and by the way the
reason I'm saying this is because you
might remember in the book I talk about
regret due to actions versus regret due
to inactions and the number one most
looming regrets that people have over
the long run are those due to inaction
you know I became a pediatrician because
my dad and his dad were pediatrician but
I hate medicine I always wanted to be an
artist and I really I feel like I I
wasted my life being a physician I
should have been an artist that that's
what really looms when you're sitting on
that porch so I think that yes in the in
the immediate point we can make certain
decisions that are good in the short
term but bad in the long term the juicy
burger you know satiates me now but I
just put on a pound but really when I'm
talking about happiness it's the
long-term view is the existential
happiness do do I wake wake up every
morning look to my right I sleep on the
left side of the bed and the person next
to me is someone that I go oh godamn
another day I'm waking up next to this
one or am I going yes I hid the jackpot
well if you make that decision right uh
correctly boy are you on your way to
happiness because I'm waking up next to
her I'm coming back at night to sleep
next to her and between those two points
I'm going off to do a job that brings me
happiness I've cracked the secret to
happiness now there are little bleeps
here and there that that are horrible
but I've made the you know the best
decisions I could in navigating those uh
different choices now by the way I
should
mention I have a quote at the end of the
book by Victor Frankle on success and I
use that quote because you can just
replace his word success by happiness
but he basically argues that you know
you don't willfully pursue success it's
something that that comes out of his out
of you making the right decision
decisions I I feel the exact same way
about happiness right I don't wake up in
the morning and say what are some
specific things today that I can do to
be happier it's not a willful pursuit of
happiness but rather life is a
navigation of statistical probabilities
right so if I make the right choices the
stats are that that's likely to increase
my happiness just like lung cancer with
smoking not every smoker will get lung
cancer and some nonsmokers will get lung
cancer but do you reduce your risk of
getting lung cancer if you stop smoking
and so I could apply that framework for
all of these decisions and the reason I
say this is because unlike self-help
books that usually guarantee you a
solution my book is not saying if you do
ABC I guarantee you happiness but I'm
guaranteeing you that it's going to
increase the probability of you being
happy that's right well Gad uh this has
been phenomenal this is a uh just a a
treasure of a book easy to read read and
full of of of great advice stories
vignettes and U my favorite part 25
densely pack pages of footnotes
references uh scholasticism of the
highest order and um especially known
for the first time only on the into the
impossible podcast that at least in one
domain Gad sad is firmly on the left and
I'm going to say you know Gad sad
reveals that he's on the left in bed um
Gad
I want to thank you so much for all the
good you do in the world making people
happy making the wrong people or the
right people mad and um I want you to do
that uh the May of EST 120 I want to
wish you a shabbat shalom that thank you
talk again soon under happy
circumstances too thank you doctor thank
you my friend thank you for watching
this episode with the wonderful
Professor Gad said conversations like
these are so important to me to maintain
my sanity and my happiness and my
biggest priority outside of my family
and research life is to keep you guys
all informed with knowledge about the
universe that's why I'm urging you to
join my mailing list at briank king.com
this is where I share exclusive content
that you can only get if you subscribe
to the mailing list like q&as with Brian
Green like Lawrence Krauss and even
future upcoming episodes with Nobel
laurates and poiter Prize winners by
joining you automatically enter giveaway
to win a 4 billion year old piece of
space mons yeah a real mediaite and if
you have a.edu email address you'll
automatically win one so go to briank
king.com and sign up today thanks again
and I'll see you in the next episode